you have interrupted a citywide
investigation you stole evidence from my
crime scene
and you got my one lead killed
I was trying to help him but you didn't
Jessica Joseph
stop talking who the hell are you My
name is Matthew Murdock I'm a returning
[Music]
how is being harlem's hero allow you to
live an actual life right now I just
want to help people
I think there's something you need to me
hey what are you doing there
who are you who are you
how come she can't be hurt
what's the deal with that fist I'm the
immortal I'm just you well you're on the
same side you for the devil of Hell's
Kitchen
oh the smartass detective we got a
problem
the righteous X goin down on the kid
with a glowing fish the war for New York
is here
[Music]
yes I know me so get your [ __ ] together
more connections you have the easier
voltage Frankie looks like an idiot
your scarf
you make quite a team now are you
talking about
bulletproof blind ninja whatever it is
you are classy
you